[Music]
let's see what type of book penny is
interested in here your perfect fit
Google what to wear to show off your
assets what to do to tone up your
trouble spots
oh you show forgiving any space to the
toxic look a certain way propaganda wear
what you want humans I got my dad's feet
episode directed by Quentin Tarantino
Sheldon and Leonard are engaged in the
time old tradition of waging thermostat
wars and I gotta say this is a sin for
anyone that thinks the thermostat should
be set above 70 if you're cold you can
put on a sweater or find a blanket but
if I'm too hot I have to fill the tub
with ice cubes and hopefully still wake
up with both kidneys can I sleep on your
couch tonight in this universe the
apartment complex has been built using
paper mache because Sheldon and Leonard
can be heard arguing through doors halls
and walls penny can not be the only
tenant to have heard their ridiculous
arguing at any point over the last seven
years by now their landlord must have
been called so many times that they
should have been evicted crazy bat-crap
crazy look I grew up in church so I'm an
expert at near swears and bat-crap crazy
is not a thing you either just say BSC
or maybe batch it crazy if you're super
creative you say guano Loco I'm all for
near swears but if you're gonna do it
don't do it half-assed it just started
at the University yes that's exactly the
appropriate amount of laughter for the
fact that someone had a different
hairstyle seven years ago what could be
more hilarious than long curly hair ding
laughter ax wouldn't his apartment
number have been included in the
directions Sheldon is very particular
and I highly doubt he would have said go
to this address and then wait for a
random person to exit the elevator and
let's hope they know where I am in the
building oh I bet you here to check out
the room for rent run away dude
convenient roommate run in is convenient
apparently Glyn didn't like rooming with
Sheldon because he's out of there like a
bat out of hell
sorry wrong video these water pipes did
not exist in the first two seasons of
this show so I did they uninstalled them
and then reinstalled them or the set
design Department and the continuity
Department fought a battle to the death
and the set design department won of
course the continuity department never
really had a chance instead of fighting
they just kept hoping things would
return to the way they were before
yeah you see it's funny because in the
first episode they made a transvestite
joke and now they're paying it off by
having everyone laugh directly at a man
cross-dressing because people who are
different or ridiculous can I say funny
I'm sorry I'm a few Big Bang Theory can
we talk about this note that Leonard is
holding has it been pooed on correct hmm
we've been told that this took place
seven years before 2010 which would be
2003 but the slimline version of the
PlayStation 2 wasn't released until late
2004 Plus why would you even need a ps2
when you have a perfectly good Gamecube
sitting right there I've placed it in a
state of eternal dibs my chair my rules
Sheldon is a selfish [ __ ] all right
he's not unlikable because of his
intelligence or his nerdy tendencies
he's unlikable because he takes those
tendencies and uses them to ostracize
others and yes takes one to know one but
the points dance cathedra may irregular
may I if you want to proof that
audiences are forced to laugh at
anything in these shows just witness
this audience guffawing at a Latin
phrase when they have no idea what it
means
rasuu fall Seuss mother when do you
evacuate your bowels in the morning
around 8:00 I can't give you eight I can
give you 7:30 once per day with no
caveats the section of their roommate
agreement must have been breached
hundreds of times by now the fact that
this episode started with a thermostat
war is far more outlandish than
believing there's never been an
unexpected Thai food bowl explosion
outside of the 7:30 a.m. time frame I'm
sorry but considering Glenn was the last
one to take this room and how closely
these letters match the don't dead open
inside message in the first episode of
The Walking Dead I have to believe that
Glenn is a time traveler and went back
in time to warn Rick and I want a full
season of The Walking Bang Theory tube
and right now roommates agree that
Friday night shall be reserved for
watching Joss Whedon's brilliant new
series Firefly might as well settle it
now it's gonna be on for years Firefly
was cancelled in 2002 this flashback
takes place in 2003 and it's almost like
they don't think we can check these
things and yes they dumped three more
episodes in the summer of 2003 but a
super obsessive fan like Sheldon
wouldn't be oblivious to its
cancellation also Fox television if
either of us ever invents time travel we
agree our first stop will be this
meeting today in precisely 5 seconds
that's disappointing now see that's
funny the show does actually have
flashes of brilliance which makes it
even more frustrating that so many of
the jokes land so flat it's like they
can't tell they're handcuffing
themselves by prioritizing quantity over
quality dammit I'm accidentally talking
about myself again aren't I
stupid hypocrisy handcuffing my genius
I'm here because you violated our
roommate agreement specifically Section
eight visitors subsection C females
paragraph four coitus except you said
that's television and movies section
nine miscellany earlier which means TV
and movies were section eight you can't
have two section 8 Sheldon 12 hours my
god I know all right so how did he not
shame Leonard for his willingness to
someone he met less than 12 hours ago
but instead aiming at Joyce camp careful
there B BT your gender specific
slut-shaming bolt is showing okay let me
get this straight
thanks for the after a commercial recap
but how many layers of nail polish are
we adding to Penny's feet in this
episode is she taking the 100 layer
challenge Jesus move on to a different
prop all ready does she is buttocks
right right oh you did did you
this goes on for some time also there
was no way this haphazard tapping is
hitting the right buttons I had one of
those devices in 2003 and I felt like I
was playing a game of operator just to
type a four-letter word and I type a lot
of four-letter words why are they still
holding their controllers in real life
if someone shuts down your Gamecube you
put down the controller and curse them
out for being an [ __ ] here they're
obviously actors excited to have a
problem fondle their C stick so they'll
never let it go good question there are
so many ways to skip all the bull that
we just saw and get to the real story
but Leonard suffers from something most
storytellers do rambling for the love of
their own voice you'll be sorry you
wasted your money on an iPod when
Microsoft comes out with bears zoom
zingers zingers you're protected by your
turtleneck and it's a Dickey is it that
I mean I've heard people call mock
turtle Nets Dickies before but I always
thought a Dickey was a fall shirt front
and a collar worn under a tux I looked
it up on the Internet and apparently
it's both how could it be both someone
asked me to tuck my Dickey back into my
pants the other day and now I don't even
know what she meant or why I spent the
night in lock
I know this is a long-running and
well-loved gag but after watching this
episode I really doubt Sheldon's reasons
for loving a particular seat wheels out
like boys at the top of the show he said
this seat is ideally located both in
relation to the heat source in the
winter and a cross Breeze in the summer
which means he's fine with the breeze
but then demands to switch seats with
Howard because the draft on my neck over
here he also tells Raj he needs to be in
his seat because I have to keep turning
my head when he lands in his spot he
also has to turn his head to converse
with everyone my point is what we all
know in our hearts Sheldon is an [ __ ]
how do you know he said that you left
the room penny would be banging it
cinemasins
have you ever noticed TVs and sitcoms
are always toward the middle of the room
instead of up against the wall where
normal humans put them this is of course
because the audience isn't allowed to
see the screen because then they would
know what's being watched it's bull and
also because there's no wall opposite
the action because well the cameras
can't shoot through the p'tee be makes
that lack of a wall obvious and
distracts me every single time that's
right the fourth wall doesn't even have
to be broken for me to sit it that's how
good I am at this very bad thing as
scientists or doctors or whatever these
guys are they are very unprepared for a
dangerous chemical reaction to go
sideways no eye protection skin
protection lung protection or protection
I'm an idiot
and I would have at least cracked the
window and put a salad bowl down my
pants for the elevator
Leonard is smart right he knows this is
about to explode and his first thought
is to wait for and then enclose himself
in an elevator not only did Sheldon save
my life he didn't rat me out to the
landlord he also waited quite a while
before decided to save Leonard's life
Sheldon flips the flag and doesn't join
the guys in the hallway right away even
though he knows the fuel is going to
explode it is solely for the lols that
Sheldon jumps in at the last moment to
get Leonard out of the elevator
in reality Sheldon should have
intervened when Leonard started walking
down the stairs
imagine if the elevator had an open
Sheldon would be knowingly waiting back
in the apartment and Leonard would be
dead but also Leonard should be in jail
anyway it wouldn't take Benoit long to
tie the chemical signature and
containment unit of that rocket fuel to
the lab you're working at so your
reasoning for not being in jail right
now still has a donut hole or two in it
why do I smell methacrylate it's
actually pronounced methacrylate and
it's technically only the joyner part of
the methyl methacrylate which is what
you're actually smelling who's the nerd
now no dialogue pop meet kettle
it was so naive just like I was seven
years ago oh I bet you're here to check
out the room for rent you please tell me
why your dad has a secret barn full of
walkers it's creepy
for all I knew he was the crazy one your
area of study is physics
I got experimental physics good
I passed the barriers oh my god Becky
look at her butt